now interviews from this year's
washington ideas forum co-hosted by the
atlantic and aspen institute
it brings together political leaders
administration officials business
entrepreneurs journalists and science
and technology experts among the
speakers in this portion whole foods ceo
walter robb
talks about bringing his store to urban
areas of the us such as detroit and new
orleans
this is just under an hour
thank you steve we're in for a real
treat
today thank you so much for being with
us and i should say thank you for
writing this book if you have not
read any of her books you should dive in
particularly to dive into the book
americana which is
so interesting and of this moment
because it provides this
window and at the same time a mirror
into issues of race and culture
and class um in this country but also
on the continent of africa and i want to
talk a little bit about
your experience in writing the book but
also the experiences that led to it for
people who haven't read americana can
you just give us
a quick sketch um so americana is about
a young woman a family who leaves
nigeria when she's a teenager
comes to the u.s spends 13 years and
then goes back to nigeria and in those
13 years many things happen
to her and it's also about obinze who is
her
childhood love who lives nigerian goes
to the uk
and who then returns to nigeria so it's
it's for me it's it's a novel about
leaving home as much as it is about
going back home
and really about what home means and if
you can go back home
and they go back home in both cases to
places that are different
and they are very different they are
they they
have been changed um by leaving home
but i think they've also come to see
home differently
i think that they've changed in a way i
think we all change as we age
of course and now we are and the hope is
that we change for the better but i
think they've changed in a way that's
different from how they would have
changed if they hadn't left home
and while americana is not really based
on my experiences because my life is not
just
very interesting ephemerals is a lot
more interesting than my life
but i and my life was easier in many
ways than the characters but i
i was in the u.s for four years before i
could afford to go back home
and even then just four years later i
had this feeling that nigeria had left
me behind
but i had wanted in that sense in which
you you leave home and you create home
in your mind and then you go back and
it's it's not what you've built up in
your mind and
and there's a sense of loss because you
imagine that
things happened and you weren't there
and
how much of of home is also tied to
identity you were asked this question
recently and your answer was um
was was sort of puckish you were asked
where is home and you said home is where
my best shoes are
this is true and in that case it was
nigeria but when you're thinking about
identity and the identity attached to
home that's something that if mello went
through also
and that that you probably struggled
with when you left philadelphia
after college to go back home how are
those two things tied together
it's interesting i think that identity
is such an interesting thing and that it
i find that in my life my identity has
had a lot to do with where i am you know
that identity shifts based on where one
is
really and so when i was when i came to
the us i i found myself taking on a new
identity
oh no rather i found a new identity
thrust upon me
thrust upon you here i became black in
america
and i really hadn't thought of myself as
black in nigeria
i think that identity in nigeria was
ethnic it was religious
but race just wasn't present and in some
ways
i think it is in southern africa for
example but not in west africa
and i guess for historical reasons um we
didn't have people staying and take over
our lands
so how did that happen to you i mean
when you came here how was it
made how were you made aware that there
was a particular box
that you were supposed to occupy as a
person of color as a black person in
america
i think of this moment as sort of the
defining moment i'm
in class it's the first essay we've
written for a class and the professor
comes in
and he says this is the best essay in
class and i want to know who wrote it
and he called my name
and i raised my hand and he looked
surprised and it was a very small
fleeting moment
but at that moment and i had been in the
u.s only a few weeks
but in that moment i realized that he
hadn't expected the person who wrote the
best essay to be black
and so what it taught me at that moment
was that to be black in america meant
something
and so discovering this identity it
wasn't so much that i
you know i like to say i'm happily black
so i don't have a problem at all with
sort of having skin like a lot of
chocolate i'd like
but it's that in this country i came to
realize that to have that
meant something that it came with
baggage and with all of these
assumptions and that
the idea of black achievement was a
remarkable thing
whereas for me in nigeria it wasn't
it was known and i think that's when i
started to
internalize what it meant and that's
when i started to push back
so for a long time i didn't want to be
identified as black and and how would
that
how would that come up if someone said
you were black i would you would tell
them i would say on those forms that
have you take
what you are i would take other because
i would say no i'm not and then i
remember i'm human
right i yeah by the way right now i very
happy little black i just want to make
that clear but
um i think and then i remember this
young man referring to me as sister and
i thought no
i'm not your sister again it was my way
of distancing myself from this identity
that i
had learned had very negative
connotations but what it took for me was
reading learning asking questions i went
on this
self-styled reading
journey where i read a lot of
african-american history
and american history and i started to
understand i started to
to let go of certain stereotypes i think
it's very easy when you're an immigrant
and you come to this country it's very
easy to
it's very easy to internalize the
mainstream ideas
it's easy for example to think oh the
ghettos are full of black people because
they're just lazy and like to live in
the ghettos
because that's sort of what mainstream
thinking is
and then when you read about the sort of
the american housing policies
of of the past 100 years
it starts to make sense and then it
forces you to let go of the simple
stereotypes
so that's what i did but it was it was
um
it was a conscious effort and it was a
an interesting journey but still a
journey
when you write about this in the book um
you write
about african americans
and africans um and the way that they
look
at each other and there's a lot of humor
in this but there's there's also some
things that
um that people will find recognizable
you'll laugh out loud you'll squirm
a little bit when you read this book was
that your intention that you wanted
people to do both of those
yes i was hoping people would be
uncomfortable it always makes me very
happy making people uncomfortable
no but really i mean i i never set out
to i think that
my i'm not i don't believe in provoking
for the sense of provoking and just for
the
i find that not very useful but i do
think that
there's certain conversations and
certain things that i think need to be
said and need to be addressed and
hopefully
need to be made better and that for
those things to be done we need to get
to a place where we are uncomfortable
and if squirming
um is a consequence of that then i think
that's fine
so leaning into discomfort yes i think
this comfort
is a necessary condition for
um for a certain kind of justice a
certain kind of progress
yes when you write a book and you put
a story out there and in some ways this
was also your story
when it's so personal those stories come
back to you and i'm interested that you
wrote a book that touches on so many
sort of hot button issues you went there
on these issues
what came back to you now that you've
been traveling not just throughout
america but throughout the world
talking about that book and talking
about these issues how do people respond
to it i love that you said you went
there because actually a number of women
have said to me mostly black women
so you went there girl you went there
yeah
everyone said i can't believe you went
there which for me actually i have to
say is one of the loveliest compliments
i have received about the book there are
people who um
you know the people for whom i think the
novel then becomes a kind of
not so much a validation of their own
experience but a i think that as human
beings we want to see ourselves
reflected in stories
and i think that that novel for many
people is a reflection of a story that's
theirs
but hasn't really been told they haven't
really
seen that reflected in in contemporary
literature i think also there are people
who are uncomfortable um
there are people and i find this
particularly in the us i find that for
british readers
british readers are all very happy to
say to me oh isn't racism in america
terrible
so to which i then say well you could
look in your backyard you don't actually
have to go
it's not very right i find that american
readers
um there's often sometimes a
defensiveness where people will say to
me well what about racism in nigeria
and i think well but that's not what the
book is about you know it's sort of like
saying
let's talk about mangoes and somebody
says well what about rabbits or
something it's really random
and but i also find that for for a
number of people it's it's also a
learning
tool that the people who've said to me
that the book made them think
differently about things
and i really value that i i find it i
mean lately i've been thinking of the
idea of storytelling as social utility
how we can actually through telling
stories start to understand one another
better
and so people who've said to me i read
your book and i'm starting to think
really differently about some things it
makes me very happy and
i hear that quite a bit so it's people
thinking differently about race for
example but also thinking differently
about black women's hair
you spent a lot of time talking about
hair in
in the book i spent a bit of time yes
i think that i think that hair i think
that black hair in particular i think is
a very interesting subject and i think
that
you know whole novels have been written
about baseball so why can't we write
whole novels about hair it just seems to
me
is that one of the things that american
women comment on in particular
because you know a lot of what happens
i'm gonna let you in on a secret there
are things that happen in a beauty shop
that you're not supposed to talk about
outside the beauty shop it's sort of
like what happens in vegas stays in
vegas
um but you take that conversation and
put it on the page
for everybody i do yes
but hey um not everything there are
certain things i didn't present
no but i felt i i think you know yes
it's the story of sort of the hair salon
but i think it also
that in a larger sense it's a political
that's that
that the hair salon is a political space
i think it is and
and the conversations that happen there
about agency yes
it is very much so and so it was
important i think it was important for
me to i don't think i could have told
that story and it's also a story of a
female
as the character coming into her own in
many ways
that's kind of a hackneyed expression
but it's still true that she becomes
fully herself and
and that journey involves the hair salon
as a political space you talk a lot
about um
the danger of a single narrative
when one story um defines
an entire class of people an entire
community and right now
one of the things i know you're a little
bit concerned about is the relationship
between
america and africa and a single story
sort of overtaking that narrative and
and right now the concern that that that
single story might be something that
we've talked
quite a bit a lot about today is ebola
right
ebola seems to be the latest i suppose
every there's kind of an ebola panic in
this country i was in nigeria
i've been here the past month so i was
in nigeria when we had ebola in nigeria
we've been declared ebola free and
watching the american reaction to ebola
has been very interesting to me because
one of the things it's it's i've been
happy to observe that
watching all the sort of the fumbling
and and the mumbling that's
been that's around that subject has made
me realize that
not dealing well with this sort of thing
is not the exclusive preserve of
nigerians
and which has been a nice thing to learn
but also i think the way that it's been
covered in the mainstream american press
has been very troubling to me
the way that the distinctions are not
made
so it just becomes this africa right so
people will say you've come from africa
therefore you're likely to have ebola
and i don't mean sort of fringe
reporting i mean mainstream
ostensibly you know responsible press
and the way that even nigeria has been
covered so nigeria has been ebola free
but
i i in reading the coverage in the u.s
it's been attributed to everything but
nigerian action
so that the u.s newspapers will say it
was because the cdc sent experts and it
was because so and so and it was because
you know cookie monster came down but
but the thing is
the reason that ebola was was contained
in nigeria was because of nigerian
action it was largely because of
nigerian action but that hasn't been
told
and i think the reason it bothers me so
much i think is because it feeds into
the same
old narrative of africa as a place with
no agency
um you know if anything good happens
there it has to be attributed to
somebody
else that's somehow not of that place
and and it's not even so much about
offending
me or offending anybody it's also just
untrue it's factually
wrong and i think that the american
readership that's been served that kind
of garbage
it's a disservice to them because
they're not being told the truth
and um so yeah i mean the whole
ebola coverage and the way that it's
been the way that the african
presence has been turned into a kind of
um
this scary other thing is very worrying
to me
there's no humanity when you wrote this
book you said that you very much wanted
to encourage people to become more
curious about africa and more curious
about race and more curious about
storytelling
and i think you have probably achieved
all of that and more thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you so much i read i wept it was a
wonderful book
thank you thank you michelle
whole foods which blazed a trail for
organic and locally grown food is
recently invested in storefronts in
low-income neighborhoods in chicago
new orleans and detroit in an effort to
bring healthy foods to
underserved communities the man behind
this effort
is our next guest walter robb he's led
the chains foray into some of
america's poorest enclaves today rob is
here with the atlantic's
james beard award-winning food writer
corbie cummer
[Applause]
then don't deny it
we'll turn the mic on we hope everyone
in this audience shops at whole foods
and don't even try to deny it
um in my own jamaica plain a
neighborhood of boston massachusetts a
few years ago whole foods decided to
come in as it turns out
down the street from walter's brother a
neighbor
and the two years of community
protests that greeted it how awful that
you're going to bring up property values
in the neighborhood we hate you
the main reason being because jamaica
plain had been a mixed neighborhood
there was great concern about
what would happen to the lower income
people who
would might be priced out from what
would otherwise be viewed as a
salubrious
development for the neighborhood it was
fascinating to watch this because
it was really at least in jamaica plain
and we're going to talk about
other conflicts we're not going to go
right into detroit
but in jamaica plain at least it was
largely extremely
well-meaning um liberal food people
like myself who were saying please think
about the consequences please think
about the latino produce because it had
been a
latino market in the space that you were
going into
and you must think of preserving this
neighborhood mayor menino of boston
made sure that there would be bodegas
and in fact the whole foods itself has a
huge latino produce area
but when i would talk to people i've
lived there for a while and i would talk
to people who lived there
35 years as urban pioneers and it was
extremely dangerous to live there they
would say
we're counting the minutes till whole
foods opens um
and so there's this great conflict and
dichotomy about everything whole foods
represents now
just now when we were talking about the
fact that whole foods is about to open
in
a poor neighborhood of chicago englewood
right there's tremendous attention to
this
and someone directly challenged mr rob
and said
well how do you expect anyone to be able
to afford to shop there
so detroit how does anyone afford to
shop there and what was your idea in
going into
detroit chicago and now a third store
like that
well good morning roy let me start with
three ideas number one is there is a
disparity of food access in this country
that is startling and stunning and is
morally repugnant there's 6 500
communities in this in this nation that
do not have access to fresh
food in a way that many of you do and
take for granted
number two is there's an idea that a
company in a community there's an
ideology around what that looks like and
how those conversations goes and needs
to be challenged and changed and in that
change creates real new possibility for
all sorts of communities whether it's us
or any other company i believe can
happen number three
this idea of diversion and inclusion and
cultural diversity and the idea of
cultural relevance matters in these
conversations in ways that i don't think
gets
the attention it deserves so in detroit
for example i think we just really
started with
uh instead of saying we're coming we
started with a year worth of
conversation at the invitation by the
way of
the secretary of agriculture and some
other folks in the community who said
would you please take a look
we do not have uh food access in this
community you know the story of detroit
two million people down to seven hundred
thousand people a city flat on its back
and yet when i went there as an
entrepreneur
in you know for many years seeing the
community in the making
and so we started with a year's worth of
conversation what's important to you
what matters with you
respecting and meeting people where they
were so to open the store by the time we
got to the decision to announce the
store
we took another year and a half to build
it out and during that time we we had a
conversation with the community there
was
there was a group an activist group that
was formed that challenged us on
hiring on investment on all these sorts
of areas so it was
and we took them on a bus out to the
oakland county stores had them give us
feedback on what worked and didn't work
ultimately we evolved our business model
the costs are obviously much lower there
we
lowered our gross margin lowered our
prices broadened our selection
uh and as a result i think we've been
able to get some choices to the
community that they haven't had
out here to ford i wonder if in detroit
there was the same in jamaica plain
there were many calls for whole foods to
begin
a subsidized housing fund for the people
who would be displaced by the higher
income
was there such an idea in detroit i mean
did you have calls like that
you have to physically you have to make
good by actually
paying people um money for the increased
property values
so here's the issues that surface racism
elitism and gentrification
all issues that are somehow and not
being examined really at a deeper level
that really need to be if these things
are going to be met these challenges are
going to be met so yes
uh people challenge us around that the
best way to go at that is to start again
by respecting people where they are
respecting the fact that there's a
community there
you are joining a community you are not
you are not
you know a white star dropping in with
some sort of great regalia from heaven
you are
joining a community that's already in
formation in the case of
of detroit i mean this is an iconic
american city
so you start with the respect for that
and uh and i've honestly forgotten your
question i'm so sorry
did anyone did anyone wound up there did
anyone in detroit
say build us uh yes yes yes they did
they said because
we're concerned about we're concerned
about what's going to happen to housing
uh and they started to create you know
and that was the first
you know i can tell you that
conversation is a little different in
chicago than it was in detroit because
we didn't really know what we were doing
and
the conversation surfaced more after the
store was open as people began to see
okay what's happening with housing
there were some developers that were
moving folks out of fixed income housing
and and the units were beginning to
change
and i could see that while they didn't
lay it at our feet
they did say our coming in was at a
change so we should talk about
gentrification we should talk about the
fact that
neighborhoods do change and how are we
going to talk about that conversation
differently than just saying
okay whole foods comes in it's
gentrification there's a deeper cut at
that conversation do you want to do that
now or um i'd like to do some of it and
i'd like to say
pull us back from you had a year of
conversation before you
did you wanted this cultural sensitivity
or understanding the people there
better uh same thing with jamaica plain
i mean it was like
you were forced into that conversation
but you didn't tell us why you wanted to
go
jamaican plane is not an underserved
neighborhood uh whatever people would
like to
believe about the way it was you were
going into literally underserved
neighborhoods as you will be doing
inglewood what's behind that decision
in the first place you know honestly uh
at this point i've been doing this over
30 years
and you know our mission as a company
and we are we started out when when no
one really knew what natural food was is
to bring healthier food to the world
that's why we did it then that's why
we're doing it now
and at some point with this particular
skill set we have as a company
uh this idea that if you look at the
life expectancy in detroit
it is 12 years less in the city than
outside the city
if you look at the statistics in
englewood and chicago where we're headed
now eight years less this is chicago
public health department statistics
that is human potential and for me as a
grocer
uh at some point it's moral it's a moral
question it's a moral challenge how can
it be
we didn't start in business to serve
some communities we didn't we didn't say
we're gonna serve
healthy food for some people the mission
is to serve people healthy whether it's
us or any other grocers
i want to see that change i want to see
access to healthier food change so for
me
for whole foods we're you know it's
about it's about fulfilling our greater
mission
i think a lot of people have the idea
that you go into a very underserved
neighborhood
you'll cure the food desert it's like a
mirage it's like a vision of the gates
of paradise but in fact no one will be
able to afford it
and they will you will actually be
bleeding them dry
of their almost non-existent disposable
income
with your extortionate prices so
what what do you answer to that how do
you really feel about that
how i answer that is this first of all
detroit's now been open for 16 months
and uh i will tell you that uh you know
it's
the greatest the greatest standard i set
for that store is i like to i'd like to
be able to walk in that store 16 months
later and feel the community in the
store feel that we're serving the
broader community that's what we set out
to do there
and i think we're succeeding so far and
so the fact is it's a voluntary decision
people do not have to shop there they
can choose to shop there or not i think
they see it as being
something very positive so the evidence
is in at least in that community that
people like what they see
they find it affordable they're able to
use it our food stamp usage in that
store is six times the company average
so again suggesting that we're having a
higher penetration
is that six times zero no no what was
food stamp
usage in the other store i'm not i'm not
playing funny with you here seriously i
we haven't given out those numbers just
because we're a public company got to be
careful with those sorts of things
no no our company we do take food stamps
and food stamps are redeemed
but in this particular store in detroit
and also in new orleans by the way the
usage is six times
what happens in the rest of i'm simply
pointing out that the the broader
community is being served
yes we're lowering we've lowered prices
we've broadened our selection we've
played
much more you know we use this as an
opportunity to learn
about uh how to take our quality
standards which we have not compromised
in the offering by the way
and it's the same quality food that's
offered at any whole foods and bring and
make it affordable selectively in
different areas by making sure that they
have a better range of choices and
that's what we're doing
did you actually i love snapchat
and i love snap usage so i i'm
completely glad to hear about that
did you have to change any of your
internal accounting systems to
accommodate an anticipated rise in snap
usage
no we didn't have to do that we we
expected we expected it to be
greater we didn't expect it to be at the
six seven time level but i tell you the
program we cannot crack
is wick and wick is another program for
for uh nursing mothers
women you'd think that you'd think that
you could get that program to work as
well and but it's so
it's so rigid as to only certain brands
are accepted and we cracked that we went
to the
secretary vilsack we went to the state
of michigan and we tried to we just
could not get through it so as a result
we were not able to
to crack that program but the food stamp
program were able to do that and of
course you're
you're familiar with the double bucks
efforts in a number of communities where
it started in boston with wholesome the
wholesome way foundation it's the way
bounty bucks double the food double the
value of food stamps that are used for
fresh produce
that's exactly right so and what they
found is that the sort of the sort of
suggestion was well if you they won't
buy fresh produce well the the data is
now in from uh
this is the fair food network in ann
arbor michigan has really done the best
work all up on the web or in hesterman
that the data shows very clearly that
with those incentives in place the
produce usage goes
crazy so they they do buy it so it's uh
there it is um
well that's great that you're going to
these neighborhoods isn't it part of a a
much broader push toward kind of smaller
stores more geared to
neighborhoods i wouldn't call it a
broader push i mean we build all size
stores is all over so we have 400 stores
now we're building another 41 this next
year
this is part of an effort really around
uh pushing ourselves into the inner city
communities to try to make a
contribution
i'm under no illusion that we're the
we're the solution
but i think that our efforts have been
contributory towards a better
environment i think it's encouraged
other companies to come there
and i hope that this sort of idea of how
a company thinks about coming to a
community
i think it has huge potential so uh this
idea of of respecting and meeting people
where they are
recognizing that that you're that you're
joining a community that's already in
in process and you thinking about it
differently what your responsibilities
are
in that in that joining and i'm
passionate about that because this is
what's happening right now in
in in new orleans when we've done our
store there in mid city brought in
bienville
and also in in englewood which is
everybody know englewood in the south
side of chicago i'm in the south side of
chicago and the mayor has done a
fantastic job
focusing on these questions of food
access through his increased farmers
markets changing
we're allowed to name him here my friend
my friend and your friend rahm emanuel
is has done a very wonderful job he
personally called me and asked if whole
foods would come to the south side of
chicago that's how involved he is
and he's done some great innovative
policy things with farmers markets
with bus stops with urban gardens with
with
repurposing news stands to be fresh
produced with mobile buses all this is
happening under his watch
he's brought a number of groceries to
the south side it's amazing if you go to
chicago the north side and we're there
lots of choices south side no choices
and i will tell you that one of the
community meetings i think i shared this
with you
i'm sitting there with a number of the
community members and one of them looks
at me and says
walter and there's around the table
walter
there's we want some of the choices that
other communities have
he looks at me this is bishop reverend
bishop dukes he looks at me he says
walter lift us up
lift us up and again i'm a grosser
but here's the thing is you're talking
about you're talking about human
potential
you're talking about human spirit so so
look we're just part of something that
happened i'm saying to you there's 6 500
areas united states that need
some sort of additional access whether
it's us or anybody else
and need some new fresh thinking about
companies responsibilities
communities by the way have to shift too
because they'll sit down and they'll
look at you and they'll say
uh you know you guys are trouble you
guys are not going to do this right you
guys
you know sign a benefits agreement
because we don't trust you
and that's what i realized in the first
meeting in detroit that i looked across
the table there was no
trust and without the currency of trust
there is no possibility
unless you're willing to change how you
think so i'm asking another trust
question which is apart from all these
fascinating questions we're talking
about trust in how
the produce has been raised and the
fairness and equity to workers
there are many systems that i personally
am fascinated by
rating systems and welfare standards but
whole foods has decided to go alone
and kind of create your own system of
standards and just two weeks ago
that's right you released something i
wanted to ask you about that
and why you decided essentially to
create your own rather than going with
any other
established criteria well because there
simply is no standards for conventional
produce in this country
and there's there's nothing that exists
and so you buy organic produce or you
buy conventional produce what is that
you don't even know what it means you
have no
transparency no visibility into how that
produce has been raised including
where it's been raised offshore and how
it's been raised there and we know
from many reports that the usage of
pesticides is far more indiscriminate
overseas than it is here and so this
system called responsibly grown produce
which we did announce is a
full transparency into domestic produce
and and it is uh
uh you can read all about it on the web
that sort of thing but it gives you a
much
wider view into how it's being raised we
have 65 percent of our growers now on
that
on that portal and it's a broader
sustainability index so for the first
time the customer you
going to jp which i hope you are uh when
you look at this it'll be rated good
better best you can track the
the standards there and you'll have that
sort of visibility into the product that
you're buying
and we did eliminate the most noxious uh
organophosphate chemicals that are
in the dirty dozen so to speak those
have been eliminated uh six or seven of
them have been eliminated in this
in this go around if you want to get the
if you want to get the ranking those
things have been related to
uh child disorders and that sort of
thing and the neonicotins have been
related to b
calling disorder so there's some there's
some concerns out there that i think
this system begins to really address
plus the transparency ultimately
what do you got to hide if you're
selling something be clear
and be visible be accountable for it
well we are
grateful to you because whatever whole
foods does the rest of us in this world
have to watch
very carefully it influences everyone
else in the community
thanks for sharing some of it with us
and we're going to keep walking
thank you to walter rob and the great
corby comer
thank you thank you
now how many of you read the reparations
cover story in the atlantic
hands up everybody everybody even if you
didn't read it you should put your hand
up
and make sure you read it uh tahasi
codes cover story
the case for reparations set a single
day traffic record for a magazine story
in the atlantic.com
tanahasi made his case for reparations
through a deeply reported
investigation of systemic racism america
in america
ta-nehisi is now on stage today with
alex kotlowicz a good friend
the author of there are no children here
the story of two boys growing up in the
other america
kotliwitz's investigation has earned him
a reputation
as one of america's most important
social critics tonight
coates and alex kotlowitz
so alex is great um i just want to make
that really really quick i've had the
opportunity through the atlantic to
interview
uh a lot of people when i was a much
younger journalist and i had
aspirations for what sort of you know
journalists i wanted to be there were
certain names that were bandied about at
that point
darcy frey katherine boo and at the top
of the heat was alex kotlewitz
uh his book uh there are no children
here i don't know if anybody here has
read it or how many of you have read it
but if you have not uh you should and
one of the things that makes
uh alex's journalism so uh incredible is
there's a lot of talk uh
among people like me reporters writers
pundits etc
uh about the issues of poverty and race
in this country
and i think uh we can get mystified by
numbers
uh and statistics seventy percent of
people living like this
fifty percent of people living like this
what alex excels at
is putting a human face on those numbers
and i know uh
when i was coming up and even now it's
one of the things that i've taken as a
lesson
uh so we're gonna have a conversation
today about storytelling about how we go
beyond those numbers about how we put
human faces on uh human problems uh and
we're gonna start with with a clip from
a film um
alex did the interrupters which is about
a group of
activists in chicago who go to some of
the roughest areas of the city and do
their best to interrupt
conflicts that you know usually would
result in a murder or homicide
it's great film um alex you want to give
sure uh very quickly
just so you understand this three and a
half minute clip um what we're about to
see is one of the interrupters kobe
williams
um he gets a phone call from somebody he
had spent time with in the county jail a
guy but
the name of flameo and flamo it turns
out somebody had called the police on
flamo they had told the police that
flameo had guns in his house
police came to his house flame wasn't
home but they ended up arresting his
brother and
and handcuffing his mother and flameo
was enraged
and he wanted revenge and so we're about
to see this clip i just want to tell you
there's some
uh um uh rough language in it so be
prepared
um i'm sure no kids right i've covered
it maybe i'm sure language you've all
heard before
um so let's play the let's play the
video
he left me a voicemail
i got a call from a guy he said this guy
sent the police in the house somebody's
doing the legal things
say the police kicked his door in he
locked up his brother they threw
handcuffs on his mother
he talked about he knew who had sent the
police in this house
he is lucky for him
yesterday
what's up what's up what's up my man
make you laugh but if you [ __ ] with him
you better bring it on these
[ __ ] came here man had my
[ __ ] mama handcuffed
my little brother handcuffed and [ __ ]
man took my little brother one got shot
in the [ __ ] wheelchair man took him
to
but still though man you got to try to
leave that [ __ ] alone though man [ __ ]
along to
get these [ __ ] you already know
how to get in
i mean what that [ __ ] ain't gonna make
no boy it's gonna make it better for me
i'm sorry here about your brother but
still though
ain't gonna make [ __ ] no better though
[ __ ] making it better i'm walking around
my [ __ ] pistol
can you grab my phone brother i don't i
can't you know
man you crazy man out here like that
thing
thing but i ain't feeling that none of
this [ __ ] and i respect y'all you know
what i'm saying what you're doing this
thing that's cool
but [ __ ] that i'm not with c's fight
what was y'all let me just [ __ ]
can't kick in my doing what i'm saying
is we can't erase what already happened
but
the whole thing is you got to look at it
like man you can't erase what happened
you right
and you can't predict what the [ __ ] i'm
finna do you know we just had to work
[ __ ] out you officers as well
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] a problem
these [ __ ] trying to take my
[ __ ] you ain't just crossing me across
my [ __ ] mama but my mama [ __ ] i come
in your crib and kill every [ __ ]
body
two or your brother's gone if you be
gone they ain't gonna do nobody hurt
your mama
should be all right how many kids you
got
i'm clamming folk all right but i just
said so if you go to jail
who won't take care of your kids that's
the thing god taking care of us now
he gonna take care just like when i do
what i'm gonna do he gonna take care of
me too
but yours locked up before for the same
[ __ ] though man
i'm 32 years old i've been locked up 15
years in my life what that mean
what the [ __ ] that mean that's where i
grew up at
goddammit ain't no shame ain't no secret
[ __ ]
i'm tired of being out of any
[ __ ] it's poor just hell there
saw fast [ __ ] i ain't doing [ __ ] but
drinking
i ain't police here what's that on the
corner cause i know these
punk ass police still want me
[ __ ] got to kill me
man [ __ ] crazy man how can you help me
right now how can you help me i mean the
only thing like i say
the only thing i can do is try to get to
know you more spend a little time with
you and
try to work so that means you will take
me out to dinner then we can go to lunch
right now
and we can sit there and we can talk
about this [ __ ] problem that's
what you're telling me
yeah yeah i'mma hold you to that goddamn
[ __ ]
yeah we could go out and see what you
want to do now
right man yeah let me go put my pistol
up
we'll just see how rob
make sure though man he got [ __ ] on i'm
um
i ain't got none it's a rough one
i think that's one of the worst ones i
had
so go ahead you're going to fly
alex i adore that clip and i was kind of
cringing because i had when i watched i
watched it with my wife
along with both african-americans a very
different environment being here no
disrespect to anybody in the crowd
it was a much more private moment and we
we
found ourselves laughing right as we
were watching it which i mean
i was watching it again i was like is
there something wrong with laughing but
one of the things we talked about is
i think actually that laughter is very
important uh because
in that is the actual humanity it's how
you get away from the statistic and i
wondered how you felt
when you were right there right you know
it's interesting we felt like kobe that
it was a lost cause i mean it was clear
this guy was just in fact when we went
from here we went to a restaurant where
he was on a telephone uh trying to get
bullets for his
pistol i mean he was really out for
revenge um
and but i love this moment because i
it makes you squirm it's unsettling it
um
but what i love about it is it speaks so
much to what chimamanda adichie talks
about as a danger of the single
narrative that you think you know this
person
from this moment when in fact you really
know very little and in fact i thought i
knew flameo
in this moment you know here he was this
angry young black man and
just filled with rage and as i came to
know him and i don't want to give the
film away
and you see as kobe ends up spending
time with him
and gets to know him and you get to know
flamel as a full
rich complicated human being you realize
the decency in him the generosity in him
and his story actually takes a
remarkable turn in the course of the
months that we were
filming in a very good way um and so for
me this is kind of a reminder
that not to think we know people when in
fact we know
very little and kim monday actually
talks about how you know show people one
way over and over again and that's who
they become
and so what's important for me is to
spend time with people
and really get to know them the other
thing i love about this moment
is you know kobe does something so
simple it's almost laughable i mean he
takes him out to lunch
and then ultimately takes him out to
dinner down the road and
and you realize in the end all that
flamma wanted was someone to hear his
story
someone to acknowledge his grievance
which is what kobe does
she started daily newspapers did i start
a daily newsletter i didn't started i
started an alternative newspaper but i
did work at the wall street journal okay
you you've been involved in a good good
range of media at this point and i
wonder what you see as the obstacles
um toward allowing people
uh more than a single narrative and
particularly you know in the area that
you work in terms of african-american
african-americans what are the options
right well i think part of the obstacles
in our profession in journalism is time
right you go out into communities and
you've got very little time with them so
if i were
a daily newspaper reporter or a tv
reporter i'd go
catch this moment i think oh my god i
got this great piece of
film this great clip and go back and
show it without really sort of
understanding who it is
behind this behind flame i mean the
other thing to keep in mind we catch
flame
at this moment you know where he's been
drinking you know he's filled with rage
and it also so much speaks to this this
idea that people become especially in
communities like this become defined by
the one
singular moment in time and how do you
you know i think like to be that sort of
right you have to have a certain
sensitivity
did you like when you're when you're
coming up as a journalist did you know
this were you aware of this did you have
this consciously in your head i want to
develop more complete
kind of i want to give a more complete
presentation was that there was that
something you came to well it was only
there and as much as
i love fiction and i love the id and i
love storytelling and so
somehow to and this is not nothing new i
mean this of course is sort of part of
what the new journalism was in the 1960s
with tom wolf
and datolis and halberstam but i wanted
to somehow try to
figure out to get as close to writing
with the style and quality of fiction
and yet it be it non-fiction to really
try to sort of get at the soul of
human beings and it's not easy and i
realized when i started i didn't know
what i was doing
it's an incredible intrusion in people's
lives it can be
and it can be really discomforting for
them and for me as well
well one of the things i mean to do this
kind of journalism um you end up having
to spend a great amount of time with
people
how do you get them comfortable with
that fact well sometimes it's hard you i
mean i do go in and i tell people
often that you know i'm going to have to
come back over a course of weeks months
even sometimes years
and and i've had the experience where
even though i tell people and more
people
they'll still get upset at some point
along the way and say
enough is enough why do you need all
this um
but i think in the end you know what
you're trying to do is
and this is kind of a centripetal force
of storytelling is try to find empathy
and i think the only way to find empathy
is to really spend time with people
to really get to know them and as as as
deep in his richer ways
as you can we you've been reporting in
chicago for a number of years
chicago has been in the uh in the news
over the past few years for some not
good reasons i wonder how you feel uh
the country at large and i guess maybe i
would say national media
uh maybe throw some politicians in there
too uh are doing
in developing that kind of empathy and
giving a a
full portrait of the city well we're not
doing a very good job i always remember
actually when
president obama first began his run for
uh presidency he would give these
speeches about the empathy gap
and people would roll their eyes i don't
think people knew what he was doing he
knew enough to stop talking about it but
what he was what he recognized i think
in a very fundamental way is that sort
of empathy is the
is what creates ultimately creates
community you know the ability to sort
of spend time to imagine yourself as
somebody else to take that leap of
of of faith and try to imagine what it's
like to be
african-american growing up in an
englewood not too far incidentally from
the whole foods or what it's like to be
gay or
a new immigrant and we are a country
that
despite the fact that we like to think
we're all in this together are really
pretty disconnected from each other and
so for me storytelling
and this notion of empathy is the one
way to find those connections
are you are you a way of having to do
that for the reader like having to get
the reader in
into that world i mean even in writing
like writing about chicago
okay you think you know chicago but you
don't you don't really
yeah i'm always thinking about it i'm
always thinking about my readers and how
distant and disconnected they are and
also all the assumptions that they bring
to the table
and i think that's really important and
i think the other part of it is what you
did so beautifully in your reparations
piece is to sort of understand context
to understand
history how it is you get to a certain
place and time whether it's
how flammable gets to this moment how
his neighborhood has gotten to this
moment in time it's
absolutely essential i think as writers
as storytellers as journalists that we
try to make an effort to sort of
understand
how the past is so influenced the
present and is so still with us
so we were having this conversation
backstage about personal responsibility
versus
systems and i just want to finish up by
asking you in terms of journalism
do you feel like there's an appetite for
that sort of empathy for that sort of
deep you know portraiture
and you know journalistic institutions
aren't doing what they need to do to
provide the time or is it that the
audience is actually not that large for
it
yeah i i mean i i guess i'm the eternal
optimist and like to think that there's
a real appetite for that i mean it's why
we go to the movies it's why we read
fiction
it's why we tell each other stories is
because we're trying to get people to
sort of understand who we are and so
i think in fact it's the in some ways
not the only way but
the the most direct way to get people to
spend time in places they otherwise
wouldn't venture i mean stories are all
about trying to sort of understand
who we are as jim amanda said but also
try to understand
the others people unlike ourselves okay
well look guys i'm going to finish up
just where i started and that is that
alex is great
you should see the interrupters you
should read there are no children here
and he has some other projects coming up
i don't know if i should talk about him
or not
but you should be on the lookout for him
this is one of our great american
journalists thank you so much
thank you so much in some ways we've
saved the best to last and you'll be
the richer for staying uh and hearing
from the new york times david brooks
his best loved work plums uh humanity
our morals and our missteps what plagues
us and what motivates us
the washington ideas forum has
considered these things with some of the
sharpest minds around
it is fitting then that we conclude with
a look inward
here to explore character is david
brooks
thank you i am the anti-climax the only
thing standing between you and the metro
uh not that any of you actually ride the
metro uh
already hisses from the audience listen
there's been a bunch of
topics uh last couple days uh and but
there's one that's undergirding it which
is
who we are and how we behave and whether
we have character or not
and the way i frame it i've framed it a
few times at aspen crowds before
is that we have two sets of virtues what
you may call the resume virtues
and what you might call the eulogy
virtues uh the resume virtues are the
virtues you bring to the marketplace the
skills you have whether you're good at
business or
accounting the eulogy virtues are the
things they talk about you
uh after you're dead uh whether you're
courageous brave
honest uh whether you're capable of
great love and we live in a society
where everybody knows the eulogy virtues
are more important but we all talk about
the resume virtues a lot more
and we talk about public life a lot more
than private life
uh even though i would say if you don't
have that private solidity
then your public life falls apart uh we
are to morality what the victorians were
to sex
we just cover it over in euphemism uh
and yet we understand the character's
destiny if you don't have character
uh whether you're talking about aids
whether you're talking about
ebola whether you're talking about trade
policy uh it all sorts of faults
or all sorts of falls apart you have
your your scandal your watergate
uh and your system doesn't work and the
people who've actually been good at
government good at writing
have had some essential character
qualities
uh abraham lincoln suffered from
depression and out of that had a sense
of providence
that led him through the civil war
franklin roosevelt was sort of a shallow
flighty guy
until he had polio and that experience
of having polio
changed him and deepened him and gave
him the empathy he needed to be a great
president
and so we all know this but we don't
really think about exactly what
character is and so i thought just for
the last three minutes here
uh i'd try to think us through what what
do we mean when we use the word
character what exactly do we mean
i think the first thing we mean is some
constancy
that the things that lead us astray are
short-term
like lust fear vanity and gluttony
and the things that we call character
are courage
honesty and humility they're long-term
and the people we say have character
they have a consistency of action over
time
even in good conditions and bad
conditions
the second thing we'd say about
character is that somebody with
character is not sort of a free-floating
lone wolf they have a series of
connections connections to something
things that are big and that anchor them
and make them stable
in the realm of an intellect those
people have a set of permanent
convictions about fundamental truths
in the realm of emotion they have a web
of unconditional loves
in the realm of action they have a
permanent commitment to things that
transcend
a single lifetime projects that
transcend
a lifetime the third thing we'd say
about somebody with character
is that there's something solid inside
them
that you have a central spot inside
yourself the
the place where you make your decisions
especially your big moral decisions
and that core piece of you is malleable
by you
if you make disciplined loving choices
you slowly engrave
engrave some permanent discipline on
that core piece
if you make fragmented disorder
decisions selfish decisions
you degrade that fall peace corps peace
and you become fragmented
and so i think when we mean character we
mean consistency over time
and then if you look at people like
lincoln or franklin roosevelt how do
they get the character
you see a couple of traits and you see a
trajectory of their lives
first those people are capable of great
love it's hard to imagine that somebody
who we said had character is not capable
of great love
uh and love humbles you it reminds you
you're not even control of your own
brain
uh you don't choose to fall in love you
fall in love
then it decenters you it reminds you
that the riches in your life are not in
yourself
they're in somebody else and then it
elevates you
you want to serve your beloved we become
what we love augustine famously said
so it drags you down to humility and
then it decenters you
and then it lifts you up the second
thing we notice about suffering and it's
certainly true of roosevelt
and lincoln was that about
character is that in usually those
people have been through some suffering
and suffering has the same sort of shape
of love though in the inverse
suffering humbles you because you can't
control your own brain
uh you can't decide to suffer you can't
even get out of suffering when you feel
it
second it hollows you out decenters you
uh the 1950s theologian paul tillich
said that
suffering drags us beneath the busyness
of life and reminds us that we're not
the person we thought we were
tilik's metaphor was suffering digs into
the basement of your soul
and then carves through the floor of
that basement revealing a cavity below
and then carves through the floor of
that revealing a cavity yellow
carves through the floor of that
revealing a cavity below
and so you're emptied out but then it
elevates you
people have been through great suffering
don't just want a party
i i have some friends here in town who
lost a child a son
and they didn't say well we've been sad
for two years let's go out and party so
we get a little happier
they wanted to turn that suffering into
something transcendent
so they created uh so other boys
wouldn't suffer the way their son had
and so suffering elevates you up into a
realm of holiness where you're not just
chasing
personal happiness you're chasing
something transcendent
one of my heroes is a guy named uh
samuel johnson one of the greatest
essayists and journalists ever he was
born nearly dead
he developed smallpox as a young boy he
was nursed with milk
with which had tuberculosis so made him
permanently blind in one eye
deaf in an ear the small park scarred
his face he they did an operation on his
throat which they took out part of his
jaw
they kept his arm open to bleed him for
six years
he had a miserable childhood and a
miserable young adulthood he was ugly
scarred nearly blind o fish tourette
syndrome
horrible fits of depression suicide
attempts
so really dragged down through suffering
and relevant to the ideas festival he
wrote his way
to character he came came to london
worked as a freelance writer for 20
years getting nothing published under
his own name but a lot of brilliant
stuff
published anonymously he could write
1800 words an hour 30 words a minute
a friend of his uh was named law
professor didn't know anything about the
law
johnson wrote for him for free law
lectures accounting to sixteen hundred
pages
and what johnson did was write his way
to the stability of the truth he just
tried to describe
accurately the world he saw around him
and he tethered himself to that
uh and many of his aphorisms contain
that stability
realism intense honest realism uh some
of his famous ones are a man of geniuses
seldom ruined by himself
if your idol be not solitary for
solitary be not idle
etc etc and it was an impressive
struggle and that's the final thing we'd
say about
about solitude i mean about uh character
the people who have character not people
who climb an external climb
if you've seen this book oh the places
you'll go this dr seuss book
it's about the external climb to success
those are the resume virtues but the
eulogy virtues it's not about an
external struggle it's about an internal
struggle against the things you fear in
yourself
and johnson took each of the things he
feared himself his sloth his envy
and he wrote about them head-on and
named them and grabbed them and they
went away
and so whether it's love or suffering or
self-defeat
it's that same shape it's falling down
and coming up
and i think the people who have
character who can be good leaders good
writers they've all gone through that
and there's a passage that's a favorite
passage of mine by reinhold niebuhr
which captures some of this the rich
way people who are admirable really
develop
and niebuhr wrote nothing that is worth
doing can be achieved in our lifetime
therefore we must be saved by hope
nothing which is true or beautiful or
good makes complete sense
in any immediate context of history
therefore we must be saved by faith
nothing we do however virtuous can be
accomplished alone
therefore we must be saved by love no
virtuous act is quite as virtuous from
the standpin
standpoint of our friend or foe as it is
from our own standpoint
therefore we must be saved by the final
form of love which is forgiveness
so thanks